it's not the first time yeah i know
it's an it's a unusual name for
americans
and she means uh
the chosen gifts bestowed upon man from
god
really
it's an interesting name yeah sounds
like a big old joke to me
all right
uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally um i was born in the
middle east
um but i got asylum to
chicago when i was about three or four
um i mean i was raised mostly my whole
life in chicago
all right because
even before i had to pay for my
citizenship when i got you know older
adult
i always considered myself an american
you know especially when people like i
caught you know in racial trials and
stuff like that so you're either you
were born in jordan i was born in jordan
and you came to us about three or four
years old three or four yeah
exactly so you know i got a chicago
accent
yeah you do i love italian beefs
huh and deep dish pizza
um
you know i'm from chicago as well huh
i'm from chicago as well yeah yeah
west on the west side really yeah wow
okay western suburbs okay yeah yeah yeah
where were you
um kidney park orland park
yeah
but when we first moved to chicago we
actually moved oak park
and it was about like oak park there's
one block
subdivision
where all
the whole block is owned by tituses
we all like our whole family is pretty
much consecrated
in oak park was that right at one point
in time in the 60s and 70s
um
what was your family like man
interesting um
it just didn't seem
because one figure in my in my family
mainly because of my father
and i don't think he because he was just
you know he was a man with his own
simple problems and
you know he was alcoholic
in our culture
if you don't if you're not
if you're not a business owner
and you don't
you know have your own business and run
your life and have your family and have
own your own things
that you're not a man and when my dad
started to fail at those things because
he used to go to college actually when
he was in the middle east
at some really good uh good european
schools you know
because he was actually smart he was
really smart but he wasn't good at
dealing
with being undermined
like you know so when he realized he
came to america
um actually before he finished school
under under everybody's wishes and he
said you know
he wanted to go to america and own a
store like everybody else you know
and he failed at it and he drank more
and he failed at him some more and he
drank some more and he drinks more and
he failed at it some more
and he took it out on the only people
that didn't care he was rich
his family you know
my mother and us is his kids the only
people in the whole entire
you know six by billion population that
didn't care that he was a rich business
owner
he was the one that last the lifestyle
on us for it because
he felt ashamed of himself i i remember
learning this at a young age
when he would start to become so violent
with me
for no reason
and one of my first memories of that is
our understanding that is
i was sitting out there watching the
snow
this is in chicago
i've never seen snorla in my life i
lived in you know
petra you know born and patriot i never
we've barely ever heard of snow
um
you see pictures of it
so
i'm sitting there watching the snow
about five six-year-olds watching the
snow out the window like most kids i
think did
and he just came home from work
and he looked looked down at me and said
question and we said in arabic
quit the
it sounds really angry when it's stuff
like that you know what i'm saying
because it is he basically said quit
looking out the window like a jackass
and [ __ ] hit me so hard that my head
hit the ground
and i think i was about five or six
years old about this time
and i started crying instantly
but i realized he can't hate snow
one man hates snow
you know you can't hate me staring out
his window
does he hate me you know
and then i realized at a young age about
six years old
he hated himself
you know at a real young age that's a
hell of an insight for a
six-year-old yeah
i get yeah
yeah the problem is you know
at least at least for
a lot of people who never experienced
you know a violent father figure
a parental figure and it's such an early
age because i mean he didn't
he didn't spank us with belts
he didn't hit us with cords
he broke ashtrays over our heads
he pulled knives on my mother
and he you know
it was very violent
especially in the drinking years
um and that seemed to rule
the whole governing of her house was
walking around each other on her own
father you know because my mother was a
typical a whole
typically different heart
like just by total opposite
you know they didn't matter where she
could have been born she was gonna be a
great mom and that's just how she was
she was you know i love my mother to
death
i hated my father my whole my whole life
as a kid
i mean we used to actually say
when when he went when he died that we
would wear red dresses to his funeral
the same we had in arabic
you know
but the day he did die we still all
cried you know
um but at this um but you know he
he got drunk he drank
he
got more angry and he drank some more
and he got angered some more and it was
just snowball effect
and he didn't communicate with any of us
you know my mom was different the mom
was like the love and affection one held
us all together
and he was when he would get home
we would know everybody scurry to the
corners of the bedroom
stay out of his way
because it you you didn't have to do
anything to get beat the [ __ ] out of
and he was he was kind of ruthless at
the point you know i mean i remember him
smacking me in the face when i was uh no
no no more bigger than seven or eight
years old
because i was eating my corn too fast
i love corn it was my favorite my
favorite flexible you know
and he [ __ ] infuriated him but that's
why i still realize that he's he's
he's mad at himself for something i was
still trying to figure out at that point
in time because at that point i was too
scared to react
you know i never like
the first time i remember jumping on my
father's back
when he was attacking my mother with a
knife and stuff
you know i think i was about
eight or nine years old
it was like the extra it was like the
greatest feat of my life at that point
you know like i finally stood up to him
i i jumped on his back and i kept
squeezing and squeezing and squeezing
until he couldn't even breathe anymore
and he fell down because he had a knife
his hand
because he literally he broke my mom's
arm before
you know
and it just like felt like the biggest
triumph in the world for me
but it was still pretty [ __ ] hard
to understand the whole situation as a
eight-year-old kid you know
it's really advanced that you were able
to figure that out
i didn't yet yeah i didn't yet i thought
i did
i mean you think that sounds about
figured out but
it just it didn't stop though see
he stopped drinking eventually right
because my mom
was about to divorce him
and to be divorced in arabic culture
a very rare thing
so he didn't want that right
so
um
after that he promised to stop drinking
and he did this is about when i was
about
13 14 years old
he stopped drinking
but the anger
got more intense
that's what that's what see i think the
drinking actually kept it at a milder
tone
and he became more violent
when he stopped drinking
um and that seemed to dem you know
dominate our household is walking
eggshells around our father you know
um
i'm the youngest
of four siblings
the baby
i have one older brother who passed
who's three years older than me he just
passed about
a year and a half ago
um
he actually he actually died a long time
ago
when he uh
had a tragic accident when he jumped out
of a window
and hit his head when he was 18
right
i'm 38 i'm
39 years old now my brother died two
years ago
he was three years older than me
so i was 36 he was 39 when he died
but that's because he's been locked up
in a mental home
ever since he was about 18
he he never did drugs he was he was a
good big brother you know like i was
like the
bad one who went
to drugs and stuff
i was only black sheep went to drugs
and um he didn't
you know until he got a little bit older
18
you know i was starting doing drugs by
the time i was 12 14 years old
um
but just from within that one year
he took some acid some good gel to have
acid
and i was actually in juvenile
correctional just a facility i did
juvenile parole
i did about
i've been about three years in jail
before i was 17.
because i just you know i had a lot of
anger issues
that you know i brought from home to
school
so
um but my brother
after that day
he developed brain damage
and
to me if uh
when i seen him after that when i got
released out of juvenile dlc when i was
17
and he was about 20 years old
he looked at me when i seen him
and he didn't know who i was
you know
and that's when i realized
that he would never be the same again
so this is about
when he was
18 19 19 20 years old
and
i realized that right there when i
looked at him in his eyes
that he died that day
you know what i'm saying
she jumped out of the window for what
reason he jumped around here i window
when i was 16 and was he was 19. but why
because he took gel-type acid oh i see
had a bad trip and he never took drugs
he was the big brother he was the
responsible one he was he was a brother
that went out to work and brought checks
back home and i was actually already in
the streets by the time i was 14 you
know
my friends get high
you know before he ever even knew what
drugs is but it only took a short while
and just that one instant
to really like just change his whole
right life for the rest of his life
it killed who he was
what made him my brother
i surfed hedros
you know the big good big brother he was
you know all directed but what was it
the damage the injuries from the window
jump fall and being unanswered
as well it causes chemical imbalance in
his brain oh really
like we had to we had to teach him how
to re-feed himself
you know we had to teach him how to eat
from trying acid once uh-huh from trying
acid once
uh once i think it was first time trying
to answer yeah
other than that all he did was like
sometimes smoke weed and he i think he
had a
religious reaction when one time he
tried to drink a whole bottle of
robitussin you know so he was like you
know he because he wasn't
you know he was sober
a kid until
that year
and it's all from that year to that
incident changes the rest of his life
but um
that killed me man that killed
that was a black hole
like that was the black spot in our
family's heart and
that never disappeared
i could see it on my mom's face from to
this day
i could you know hear in her voice
everything on in our whole family it
just
like a wave
so the whole family changed
you know because we had so much hope for
him
you know
you know my everybody thought i was i
was going to be my typical my dad
and be the angry one and be the
drinker
and which i was just drug addict instead
from you know most of my life
but i was i was always having my my
dad's blood
the anger
you know and uh
you know
pretty much revolting
you know i guess like just going to
school and doing what's pretty much
predicted for you you know and what's
you know
sensible for you
um
and uh
yeah
he wasn't
but
the brain damage like literally he
couldn't even what we had to do to be
talked how to walk how how to eat
and he got a little better
but
in his eyes
when you look
when you i looked in my eyes
we all knew it we all knew the same
thing we didn't understand anything
we just told each other to cry
especially when i see my mother's eyes
and um he died
about a year ago
died died
because he's been in the mental homes
uh in in
[Music]
chicago and california for past 15 years
because um
he started and you know a lot of mental
cases i don't know why
they just smoke smoke eat eat eat smoke
and you end up having a heart attack a
year ago
but i caught my sister
because i've been on the streets and
stuff here
but i called my sister to check in with
her like i know me do every once in a
while
i never called my family for money ever
not once on the street
actually i think one time i asked when
corporate started i asked if i they
loaned me a thousand dollars so i can
get a place
and they said absolutely they're not i
don't give a [ __ ] if ebola takes over if
you're on drugs you're going to get
ebola before you get a sense out of me
and i said okay that's what i figured
how are you doing you know because i
used to just call and say hi you know
um that's the only time i ever had some
money
because i haven't felt like guilty
asking for money especially when they
know where i'm going to spend it i don't
need my i don't need money i don't need
drugs i need to be a sober
you know and we all knew that
and um
yeah
that was a pitiful
pinnacle
pitiful
pivotal point in my life
well it kind of just suck it's really
soft for me to everything
you know because i used to have a lot of
my dad's anger issues but i never had
women
i never drank but i did drugs instead
but my mom would always tell me
you have my heart
and your dad's mind
and that's where you battle
and between those two
she's like try to remember
me do i remember what the good things
are
when those things in your mind try to
remember
remember all the bad things you know
uh to me my mom compared compared to my
dad was the same
you know
i mean
he he's broken my nose a couple of times
a little bump right there stuff is not
from street fighter
my father
you know he used to break ashtrays over
my head and stuff
he wasn't the typical
you know go get a switch from outside or
belt or nothing
because he just
couldn't get the [ __ ] grass of
we are the only people in the world that
don't care
that you're not your own business owner
we love you as a bus driver
you know we want you you can be a father
as a bus driver
you can't be your father as your lazy
raving [ __ ] lunatic obsessed about
[ __ ] not being your own boss
so he was always a bitter person and
he's always bitter and always angry
he wasn't a talkative person you know
my mom is totally opposite what's my
family totally opposite
do you feel like the
childhood you had with your father is
kind of why you're in the situation
you're in today
i can't i can't i can't know
i mean
i could see
how a kid
and why a lot of my anger issues
affected my school life
and i didn't go to school
and i didn't want to listen to teachers
how about you in school
i actually just got my i got my ged
after my my younger adult years that you
dropped out i dropped out i started
working for construction when i was
about 14 14 years old 13 years old
yeah yeah because i went to juvenile dlc
the first time i went to juvenile dlc
was i was 14 years old
the first time i went to
juvenile detention
was when i was about 11 or 12.
and i kept getting arrested kept being
arrested you know
first was recharges and then you know
about 14 you know this time
and after i caught my
third drug case as a child
they sent me to a juvenile deal
department of corrections
for juveniles
so
i spent
my longest term there
my first term there was three months
uh
you know i had two
two terms there three three months piece
and then my last and longest term
was when when i was uh
as a child
i think four four eight to eight months
i think i believe
and i was released actually i maxed out
date
i maxed out on the charge that i was
charged with
and now
they released me at the age of 17
adult
so i was released with a clear balance
like and it was
and i felt it too you know it wasn't
just like i was clear because the some
lawyer got me out i was cleared because
the maximum years for the for the crime
i did
can be could no longer serve more years
as a juvenile
so they released me on my 17th birthday
um
by the time i was released
that's when my my parents didn't want to
tell me
what happened to my brother
until
they came all the way to
grafton illinois
that's about an eight hour drive from
chicago where we live
picked me up from there
that was the facility i was at
in the juvenile dlc system
because it's just like the prison system
it's all over the country
um
so
um
yeah i actually
started to adhere a little bit to life
after that
you know um i stopped i was sober for a
few years you know i got a couple things
together
you know and i was doing okay i moved
out
uh
i was about 18 19 with some friends
roommates
you know down the street for me
actually because my dad beat the [ __ ] on
me
so bad
i ran over there in the middle of the
night
and i didn't want to tell them what
happened
but i couldn't stop crying
and they wouldn't stop pressing me about
what happened you know the great friends
i still still talk to them to this age
still talking one one of them wants me
to be the best man
actually the two brothers both asked me
to be best man
and um
my other best friend asked me to be a
best man what do you do
and i think the [ __ ] that are all all
off too too busy being a drug addict
maybe i felt like i didn't deserve it
for whatever reason
you know
i don't know
at point times i felt like i failed my
brother after my family
because
you know i should have been more there
but i revolted more um
and that was like
if there was a book written in my life
that would be called the sadness
that those chapters
you know i'm saying
because
i actually started doing pretty good
um my dad stopped drinking
he was still kind of a bitter old man
but he was getting too old to
you know be such a threat to us so he
had to hear
his life a little bit um he actually
became a school bus driver
my mom at this point got in a car crash
and used her legs
and
she was on disability the rest of her
life
even now
um
yeah and uh
i started to do good i had my own place
i actually moved down or
i've worked construction my whole life
so
um but i never went to school until i
was about to
23
to get and i got a ged that way
because i never even got a chance to go
to high school because i was in juvenile
dlc
and you get i thought in chicago at that
point you could only get a ged uh degree
not a high school diploma in juveniles
you'll see it
so i just got out when i when i was 17
and i started working construction
i worked with construction my whole life
you know
um you've been homeless now for how long
at this point yeah i've never been home
to this point how long
have you been living on the streets not
since right now
i've been homeless
four years now four years yeah and i was
homeless before for like another
five years i believe
five five yeah you know
three years three years
so seven years total
with a little bit and break in between
is the longest then
um
um but at one point in time i started
doing good i moved
i was about 26 years old no i was 22
years old
i moved to san diego california
and
stayed with my mother there
and
i moved out got my own place i started
going to school
and like you know you know what the [ __ ]
crazy thing is
is i work construction jobs
when i was 18
then i was making 22
an hour
at the time the minimum wage in chicago
was
six seventy five seven dollars
you know i'm making more than most of my
parents
i've i've done my own side jobs i
started my own little side company and
everything
and done my own my own work
and jobs that cost literally almost ten
thousand dollars
um i put the roof on my mother's house
actually
when i was
yeah i think that was when i was 17
because that was the first job
construction job i got
was a roofing and concrete company
i put that roof from my mother's house
by myself
with the help of my teaching my friends
um
no one ever believes that either and
then
i'll tell them you can call my mom right
now and put it on speaker phone who put
the roof on your house when when you're
16 mom you did your [ __ ] and you did a
good job
you know that's that's my mom you know
she's got this cute little accent
jordanian accent moving about four foot
too tall
but that she got a heart of a beast
she she just got a heart of the beast
and brave
she's brave man she's really big
um
yeah
and that felt good that was one of the
best feelings in the world when i did
that
you know i did it on my own you know i
was leading it you know
and at first she didn't have confidence
in me but then when she at first i did
landscaping for her she seen how good i
was at it
and she let me put the roof on her house
and the roof to this day
did not leaked one [ __ ] drop my uncle
still owns the house and rents it to
other family
and he's still telling me it has not
[ __ ] leaked one [ __ ] drop
that's pretty i was about
20 years ago
20
yeah
23 years ago
um
so they knew i always had a knack for
like you know i was smart and that's
what that's what killed my family
my mom actually i just talked to you the
other day
she's like you're telling me because
you're so smart
you could do whatever you want and
everybody knows that you're talented
you know i could sing i played it i
started playing instruments when i when
i was a little older
and i just adhered to him
you know anything i wanted to do
put my mind to
i would really do it you know whether it
was
you know roofing whether it was playing
piano
you know i used to know a moonlight slot
sonata the old ninth symphony
you know
and i never even started playing piano
and instruments until i was about
20 23
my sober years you know
but i really adhered to it you know
um i lived with roommates
until i was about
26
my family had moved to uh
san diego
and um
uh arizona
and los angeles prior to this
or prior to me leaving
so i was the last family member that was
still in
chicago
um
[Music]
but you know i just i couldn't take it
by myself
and just my friends because you know how
far friends go sometimes i have a good
little good strong group sector friends
that have have gone way
like out the reaches of helping somebody
you know and most typical friends i've
never even heard of doing you know
like going my crack dealer's house that
they never knew in the middle of the
ghetto which they don't [ __ ] go
you know and screaming out his outside
of his window give us our [ __ ] e-hat
back give it a give it to us now [ __ ]
like that like you know
and um there's just always been a good
close friends
because
i actually when i moved into roommates
with an irish family
you know i remember my
buddy tony and stuff
and that's who i started really working
construction for and concrete
you know and taught me the trades of
everything him and his stepfather
the hardcore carry irish
family
and you know and they taught me a lot of
good work ethics like any person that i
ever tell you i work for him he's
probably one of the best workers you
ever see in your entire life and he
could figure out [ __ ] faster than anyone
i've ever seen
but the thing is
a lot of times
he can't stay
steady work three three months
without getting the big pay when he goes
a job somewhere
and then i don't see him on on monday
you know because i was a drug addict
my whole life that was
that was a dominating force
what is your drug now
uh i'm enjoying now is uh
crystal meth and uh
fentanyl
uh i actually just got out of the
hospital i don't know if you noticed it
was hard for me to get up
because i od
and um
when i got a hospital or bless you by
first i got locked up
got released
and i at that point
i didn't know how i was gonna get drugs
and stuff because
you know i had nothing at that point
and i was so weak
i decided to go to a good samaritan
hospital
this is just recently just now
so i was in good submarine in about
five six days
and they released me yesterday
um which i'm like it's pretty much i'm a
sober right now
you know kind of a couple puffs here and
there but
i used to do a lot more than pick up
puffs you know um how do you support
yourself
i i you know i always support myself on
the streets
um
mainly by like you know just you know
trying to stick to the
commercial
uh
you know stealing it you know
uh
yeah boosting or
or at a point in time that i've sold by
myself
you know yeah
a lot of times yeah yeah that's that's
one of the things that very few people
admit to yeah and then we didn't i was
questioning that
i was never
able to admit to it then
ever
but now i tell people hey
i've done it all man you can't you can't
you can't tell me no
i don't know you can't you can't shame
me in any type of way i've done
everything that you could [ __ ]
probably think of it some more you know
so i think honestly is the key to
getting past it yeah yeah
okay you can keep it inside but it'll
it'll haunt you for the rest of your
life yeah you say you never did it you
said it never happened
you know i'm i was never my family was
born christian right i was baptized as a
christian
but
at a young age
i
i told myself that
not that i don't believe in jesus
but that reminded because you know born
in a christian household
but that i believe in something more
than just one entity
you know
i'm leaving like there is the sense of
god and that's
the sense of
the whole point that we use
exists at all in this very point in time
in this special universe at this time is
a miracle in itself
you know just for a split second because
not even god can take back that he made
us can he
he'd have to go back and
and and now you know that he may made us
to take us back
and then he'll get rid of us right yeah
these guys are nuts
mistake number one
but even god will be aware of that so
not even god can fight our own existence
not even god himself can say that he
never created us and just our own
existence i think is the biggest miracle
in the universe
all right ihob thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you man i wish
you the best of luck
thank you i hope you figure this out
i'm gonna try you deserve something
better than this
thank you
thanks
you